the bellagio conservatory and botanical
gardens
is ringing in the holiday with their new
hopeful holidays display
through january 9. rocky is getting an
inside look with the designer himself
happy hopeful holidays from the from the
bellagio ed libby you designed this
beautiful place
every season last time we were here it
was thanksgiving and now look at you
it was and that was our into the woods
exhibit and for the first time at
bellagio
we're tying two exhibits together so
during the thanksgiving exhibit we had a
visitation from a cardinal
and we've expanded on that theme a
visitation for cardinal in the winter
against the snow
represents a hopeful visit and hope from
heaven
and that's kind of where we are right
now we have our queen receiving the
cardinal
and wishing everybody a healthy hopeful
and happy holiday season that's exactly
what we need right now and i want to
talk to you about this display back here
that is gorgeous
this is absolutely my favorite so this
is something that's been fine-tuned by
by our new conservatory manager this bed
actually represents
our entire team that puts the show
together so there's gardeners there's
engineers there's designer
there's uh floris everybody on the on
the team the little guy who runs the
fountains
there's everybody on the team that puts
this whole thing together so it's really
a tribute to the camaraderie
of all the people on our team that have
made this happen throughout the pandemic
and
dealt with the social distancing and the
limited number of people that can work
on a team here at the bellagio
but it's it's open it's gorgeous and
it's hopeful
it is hopeful and thank you to you ed
for putting this together bringing so
much life to the community every single
season
uh it's absolutely my pleasure and i
can't wait to the next one all right
thank you so much
i'll send it back to you guys